[Music]
cardi b
is putting her wild side and her baby
bump on full display
oh yes honey on monday cardi hit up
instagram posting this sexy clip
lip-syncing the chorus of wildside
her new collab with normani
[Music]
but when cardi's verse comes around the
28 year old rapper turns the heat up in
a shiny leather bikini
showing off her gorgeous pregnant belly
from every angle
shoot me like a watch let me down on the
kitchen floor right on that towel
its my can i want it now cardi captioned
the clip on
instagram quote wild side
tell me how you want it put me on my
back on my stomach baby let me blow it
like a trumpet
i
but on twitter she shared the same clip
and challenged normani to follow suit
writing your turn normani i'm so excited
and normani responded in part quote you
win
the two dropped their new track along
with the accompanying jaw-dropping music
video last week
and it was well wild
thank you i worked worked really hard
the two superstars
danced in the buff together and
absolutely
slayed the whole damn thing every other
day
come take me out of course cardi is
currently pregnant with her second child
with hubby offset
the two share a three-year-old daughter
culture
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's
it's like a feeling that it's
indescribable
it's like love joy it's a
switch you know what i'm saying it's
like
an automatic smile everything
on monday the grammy winner took to her
insta story to talk pregnancy cravings
with her fans
and for cardi it's all about the meat
i don't really eat burgers that much i
used to eat a lot of burgers when i was
younger like
a teenager in my early 20s and now i'm
back at it again and oh yeah
barbecue barbecue sauce barbecue mead
grilled meat
is a real fat craving baby
she also shared this clip strutting down
a pathway in a blue dress
lip-syncing alongside the caption my
face getting fat
you